in the world today there are 900 million
plus cars that have the onboard
diagnostic port enabled in them
we built a device that goes and plugs
into the onboard diagnostic port we call
it the connected car IOT device now what
is happening is inside the vehicle we
are doing everything but driving what
earwire wanted to do was put your hands
on the wheels eyes on the road and
everything else can be done with your
voice we basically take those vehicles
and turn them into very very intelligent
and smart vehicles this is a market
which is in in motion and in order for
us to capture that market we wanted to
make sure the app was ready with the
device and we can enable these services
from a cloud platform like what iBM has
as we engaged with the San Francisco
garage it was an amazing eye opening
experience for us the design thinking
process that we went through allowed us
to come up with things that we hadn't
thought initially we actually looked at
the real problem and and then morphed
our app to actually solve that problem
because it was real garage went out and
and looked at all the different areas
that IBM has including IBM Watson
personal assistant
IBM IOT for auto and extracted all the
stuff that this app needed anand raj
basically put it in one place and now
suddenly air wire has an app that is
ready for market in less than 90 days
and this is the advantage of partnering
with a company like IBM